let's say that we have the indefinite
integral and the function is 3x squared
plus 2x times e to the X to the third
plus x squared DX so how would we go
about solving this so first when you
look at it seems like a really
complicated integral we have this
polynomial right over here being
multiplied by this exponential
expression and over here in the exponent
we essentially have another polynomial
it seems kind of crazy and the key
intuition here the key insight is that
you might want to use a technique here
called u substitution substitution and
I'll tell you in a second how I would
recognize that we have to use u
substitution and then over time you
might even be able to do this type of
thing in your head u substitution is
essentially unwinding the chain rule in
the chain well I'll do I'll go in more
depth in another video where I really
talk about that intuition but the way I
would think about it is well I have this
crazy exponent right over here I have
the X to the third plus x squared and
this thing right over here happens to be
the derivative of X to the third plus x
squared the derivative of X to the third
is 3x squared derivative of x squared is
2x which is a huge clue to me that I
could use u-substitution so what I do
here is this thing where this little
this little expression here where I also
see its derivative being multiplied I
can set that equal to U so I can say U
is equal to X to the third plus x
squared now what is going to be the
derivative of U with respect to X D u DX
well we've done this multiple times it's
going to be 3x squared plus 2x and now
we can write this in differential form
and D U DX this isn't really a fraction
of a differential of D U divided by a
differential of DX it really is a form
of notation but it is often useful to
kind of pretend that is a fraction and
you could
kind of view this if you wanted to just
get a DUI if you just wanted to get a
differential form over here how much
does you change for given change in X
you could multiply you could multiply
both sides times a DX so both sides
times a DX and so if we were to pretend
that they were fractions and it will
give you the correct differential form
you're going to be left with you're
going to be left with D U is equal to is
equal to 3x squared 3x squared plus 2x
DX now why is this over here why did I
go through the trouble of doing that
well we see we have a 3x squared plus 2x
and then it's being multiplied by a DX
right over here I could rewrite this
original integral I could rewrite this
as the integral of let me do in that
color of 3x squared plus 2 x times DX x
times e let me do that in that other
color times e to the X to the third plus
x squared now what's interesting about
this well the stuff that I have in
magenta here is exactly equal to D u
this is exactly equal to D U and then
this stuff I have up here X to the third
plus x squared that is what I set u
equal to that is going to be equal to u
so I can rewrite my entire integral and
now you might recognize why this is
going to simplify things a good bit it's
going to be equal to and what I'm going
to do is I'm going to change the order
I'm going to put the D you this entire D
you I'm going to stick it on the other
side here so it looks like more of the
standard form that we're used to seeing
our indefinite integrals in so it's
going to be we're going to have our D U
our D u @ times e times e to the U times
e to the U and so what would the
antiderivative of this be in terms of U
well the derivative of e to the U is e
to the U the antiderivative of either
is e to the U so it's going to be equal
to e to the U e to the u now there's a
possibility that there was some type of
a constant factor here so let me write
that
so plus C and now to get it in terms of
X we just have to unsubstituted oh what
u is equal to so we could say that this
is going to be equal to e instead of
writing u we could say u is x to the
third plus x squared U is X to the third
plus x squared X to the third plus x
squared and then we have our plus C and
we are done we have found the
antiderivative and I encourage you to
take the derivative of this and I think
you will find yourself using the chain
rule and getting right back to what we
had over here